so we are getting absolutely no respite
whatsoever from the profligate barrage
of fake scandals relating to joe biden
that are emanating from right-wing media
and one thing i've learned in covering
politics is that
there are always scandals for every
president sometimes they're real
sometimes they're completely fake and
made up for political purposes no
president is perfect
but joe biden's first hundred days are
actually looking pretty good
first and foremost developing a top
global vaccination campaign after being
handed
trash by the trump administration such
that the u.s
has now vaccinated 42 percent of the
population is likely one month from
dramatic reductions in cases and deaths
probably more like three weeks even
passing covet stimulus and getting money
to people within a couple of months of
getting in with
no republican support literally zero
republican votes
for that bill reestablishing some global
relationships with countries that were
driven away by the incompetence of the
trump administration for those who
care about the stock market as many
claims to
under donald trump record stock market
highs
under joe biden and it's been three
months okay
so right wing media is coming up with
fake scandals i won't list all of the
ones we've looked at so far you know
everything from
the the relationship between joe and
jill biden is fake
to you know all these different fake
scandals there's just too many
i'm just going to focus on the ones from
this weekend alone
we already talked about the fake scandal
that joe biden would ban
meat and beer so that's one i won't go
over it again since we did that earlier
in the show
here yesterday morning is fox news
anchor
and long time trump brown noser maria
bartoromo
announcing that during the recent uh
world leader
climate zoom meeting biden
didn't have a u.s flag behind him
that's the scandal take a look at this
by the way in that shot i think it's
really also interesting to point out
that
president biden is the only leader
without a flag behind him
everybody has their flag when we don't
have the american flag
behind joe biden interestingly whoa that
is really can biden even recover from
that i mean that's really really serious
fox news is reporting about the absence
of a flag
during a virtual meeting as a scandal
they wouldn't report on trump's historic
global failure on kovid while it was
going on
but the absence of a flag during this
meeting is a scandal for fox news
here's another big scandal former
republican speaker of the house newt
gingrich
appeared on judge jeanine pirro's
weekend show
to tell us there are people that are
appalled janine
appalled that the biden administration
is quote flying the gay flag
at american embassies around the world
take a look at this
every idiotic thing that the buy
demonstration has done
in the first hundred days you begin to
realize
whether it's threatening everybody who
believes in the second amendment
or is attacking everybody who believes
in right to life
or it is attacking people of traditional
values who
are appalled that this administration
would fly the gay flag
at american embassies all over the world
i mean you just go down item by item
and it's almost like you have a
checklist biden is disrespecting people
with traditional values which is one of
the most
impotent coded phrases i can think of
he's offending people with traditional
values because
the gay flag as he calls it is flying
at embassies in other countries
people with traditional values are going
around
paying attention to the flags being
flown at american embassies in other
countries
that alone would be a shock and if
that's really what they're concerned
about
they must really not have much going on
in their lives but that's another
fake fox news scandal concocted
this weekend the next scandal is less
about biden specifically
but it's democrats bigger picture
republican congressman mike
turner was also on maria bartoromo's
show yesterday
and he floated a completely unhinged
conspiracy theory
that democrats want to block the u.s
from making a nuclear first
strike in order to prevent generals from
defending us against the
against adversaries so that if an
adversary attacks the u.s
we would just get destroyed as a country
take a listen to what mike turner said
to maria bartoromo and then you've got
democrats led by elizabeth warren
reintroducing a bill to block the u.s
from using nuclear weapons first what's
the logic
you know there really isn't any that's
for our security um you know the byte
administration is it proposing 16
increases everywhere else but in defense
um elizabeth warren obviously wants to
you know tie the hands of our generals
so that they cannot defend
against our adversaries we need to make
certain that america stayed strong that
we build a strong military that we rise
to the occasion against the
modernization of china and russia
and with that we'll be able to keep our
our allies in the united states safe
understand that what mike turner is
alleging is that there are democrats
in the senate that are treasonous and
they would allow
the u.s to just be destroyed he's saying
democrats including elizabeth warren
if the u.s were attacked they would say
do nothing
here take me take all of us kill us take
over the country
and that's crazy but also if it were
true
you would imagine that there would be
way more people saying oh these these
these are traitors
and there are people saying it but there
would be much more of that and mike
turner
is completely unhinged in his claim and
by the way uh
i i thought that we didn't have anything
to defend ourselves with remember
donald trump used to tell the stories
about when i took office the generals
came to me
and they said sir we have no bullets
we have nothing so now we have things
thanks to trump
but elizabeth warren if you can imagine
that doesn't want anybody to be allowed
to use the things
and the country should just be allowed
to be destroyed and then
here are just a few little tidbits about
the steak and beer thing again earlier
in the show we spoke about
the fake story that biden wants to ban
steak and beer
like eliminate them from people's diets
by force
listen to judge jeanine uh talk about
that finally tonight
do you like red meat and then this
continued
so the cows must go and she went with
this for some more time here's a little
bit more
yeah i like burgers and i like my gas
powered car
and i'm sick of china having the upper
hand over us
okay so that that one has actually
infected
more serious discussions about
infrastructure and biden's climate and
energy plan so
we dealt with it separately earlier in
the show and you can go back to that
segment if you want to see more
about that but in the meantime if these
are the scandals maybe joe biden is
actually doing okay
because these scandals are completely
fake and i think we can say thankfully
in the sense that it's good when polling
reflects what's going on in the real
world
joe biden's approval rating is is quite
healthy joe biden's approval on covet
vaccination is doing very well
his approval on covet relief is doing
well i i think that these are all good
signs
for joe biden one of our sponsors is
curiosity stream letting my audience
try it free for an entire month i love
curiosity stream
perfect for people like me or anybody
who watches the david pakman show
curiosity stream is kind of like netflix
for documentaries it's a streaming
service with
thousands of documentaries from some of
the best filmmakers
many are exclusive to curiosity stream
including documentaries on politics
science history
everything the curiosity stream app is
great
i use it on my tv phone and ipad
i just watched as i told you uh very
recently
engineering the future very very
interesting about potential future
technologies
and they always have the newest and most
popular documentaries
they have amazing ones that i can't find
on other platforms and
curiosity stream is just 299 a month
or 19.99 for a whole year but you
can try it totally free for one month
when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman